so Donald Trump's ambassador to the
United Nations nikki Haley is resigning
at the end of the year this was
announced yesterday trump and nikki
Haley actually did a press event at the
White House and it was all presented as
everybody's on good terms this is all
very happy
Nikki's great everybody's great but the
truth is that nikki Haley has actually
been pretty critical of Donald Trump
during her tenure as ambassador to the
UN at least compared to some of the
other totally unconscious brown nosers
of Donald Trump and according to what
Trump said yesterday he had known for
six months that nikki Haley wanted a
break after this year and everybody is
just super happy about this is what we
were led to believe but we know that
Haley was sometimes at odds with Trump's
third of three national security
advisers john bolton and this is number
one a decision a change that is likely
going to lead to even more
radicalization and it's not that nikki
Haley was Pro UN in any broad sense of
the term by no means but she is likely
more friendly to the United Nations than
whoever Donald Trump is going to end up
naming as her replacement and yesterday
I did the story about the radicalization
of American institutions and what we're
seeing is that American diplomacy
continues to radicalize when you add as
Trump certainly will a more hostile to
the United Nations ambassador you were
furthering this move to the right this
radicalization of American diplomacy now
as far as what the real the so-called
real plan is here there's a bunch of
different speculation I'll tell you some
of the top hypotheses number one there's
the suggestion that there's gonna be a
really big shake-up in the Trump
administration for 2020 and that nikki
Haley will ultimately run as Trump's
vice president for 2024 the reelection
campaign as his running mate and that
Mike Pence will end up going to the
cabinet right this is this is not what I
think is going to happen necessarily but
this is one idea another idea is that
nikki Haley is being
to run for the Senate in 2020 in South
Carolina and there's actually some
specific details about that I got one
email saying Trump is going to push
chief of staff John Kelly out after the
midterms meaning in December January and
install nikki Haley as chief of staff
which doesn't ring particularly true to
me given that again nikki Haley has been
somewhat critical of some things that
Donald Trump is said and done another
idea would be that the reason for nikki
Haley leaving her UN ambassadorship is
so that Lindsey Graham who's a senator
from South Carolina can be rewarded for
that totally unhinged Brett Kavanaugh
rant at the hearings two weeks ago and
as you an ambassador you then put nikki
Haley in as Senator filling in for
Lindsey Graham for the remainder of his
term and then she runs in 2020 in 2020
Lindsey Graham seat is up for
re-election and you would get her the
power of incumbency by having her in
there for a couple of years and then she
can actually run for that seat properly
as the actual candidate in 2020 but for
me the most interesting possibility has
nothing to do with Trump's plan for
nikki Haley it just so happens Pat I
don't know if you'll be surprised by
this I know many in our audience won't
be that Nikki Haley's resignation
announcement remember she's not actually
leaving till the end of the year came
the day after an ethics watchdog group
requested an investigation into her
flights on private jets the watchdog
group is claiming that she improperly
disclosed I think it's six or seven
flights on private jets on her 2017
financial disclosure a lot of problems
with private jet and first-class jet
travel for Trump people and this is
interesting timing to say the least this
is completely in line with what Tom
Price did and well Steve minuchin did
but it could all just be coincidence I
mean this will be two full years for
nikki Haley as the UN Ambassador yeah
it's not like at the beginning of the
Trump administration when people would
leave after a month or two and we were
wondering why are they leaving so early
I think there are fewer questions with
this one
there are
you were questions but they're still
question and we know that a really good
way to get federal ethics probes to go
away is to resign and now she's not
actually leaving until the end of the
year and how that would play into a
possible ethics investigation is less
clear but Citizens for responsibility
and ethics in Washington has filed a
complaint they want a full investigation
into this they want the Inspector
General to explore these seven flights
on private jets paid for by three South
Carolina businessmen did she resign
yesterday or announced her resignation
yesterday because of this I don't know
what I do know is that it's too easy to
get out of these ethics investigations
by resigning that that's in no other
world are you free to go like if you get
into your car before the police catch
you and say we want to talk to you about
something you say I made it into my car
the police don't say oh you know you did
you're in your car we're not going to
talk to you we're not going to explore
what it is we think you did wrong that's
basically the way it works with federal
officials and these ethics
investigations so anyway which is the
most likely explanation I don't know but
nikki Haley is going bye-bye and there
are important policy implications which
is which relate to the question of how
Trump is going to have a replacement
influence the relationship of the United
States with the UN which to use Trump's
word is an increasingly beleaguered
relationship and this really matters and
lastly let me throw in could Donald
Trump be thinking of replacing nikki
Haley with his own daughter not Tiffany
he seems to camp seems he can't stand
Tiffany at all Ivanka Trump could Ivanka
Trump be Trump's idea of the next
ambassador to the United Nations
he couldn't they wouldn't let him right
well let's talk about that next we have
to talk about something today that is
going to make some of the people in our
audience extremely uncomfortable because
it turns out that Donald Trump
disproportionately appealed to
cognitively challenged voters to vote
is likely to perform poorly on
intellectual ability tests now I want to
issue a disclaimer here because I know I
know what's going to happen Pat we know
what the response will be if you were a
so-called race realist who wants to just
go where the evidence takes us if you're
in the facts don't care about your
feelings crowd if you're against
claiming to be offended to shut down
debate because being offended isn't an
argument I'm glad you're here because
you then must allow the facts to lead
you where they may and they lead down
the path of Trump voter voters being as
a whole less intellectually capable than
Hillary Clinton supporters on a totally
standard test known as a solid indicator
of intellectual ability this doesn't
mean every Trump supporter is dumb this
doesn't mean that some smart people
don't support Donald Trump it just means
that in total in the aggregate Donald
Trump was disproportionately supported
by voters with lesser intellectual
ability and more cognitive challenges
than Hillary Clinton the research team
was led by yo of gonza of tel-aviv
University now if you're a race realist
you should really believe these results
because Jews supposedly are the smart
ones according to the race realists and
we've got a guy from tel aviv university
named you have gonzaque who's going to
give us the results this is the most
credible source of information is how
can you argue against that for the race
real absolutely the study analyzed data
from the American national election
studies report and it points out that
quote intellectual factors played an
important role in the 2016 election
these results suggest that the 2016
presidential election u.s. presidential
election had less to do with party
affiliation income or education and more
to do with basic cognitive ability the
subjects of the study were given a basic
verbal abilities test which is widely
accepted as a pretty good indicator of
overall cognitive ability and the Trump
supporters were under-equipped relative
to Hillary Clinton voters higher verbal
ability education cognitive ability we
associated with supporting Obama over
Romney in 2012 and with Hillary over
Trump in 2016 this is interesting on a
few levels first of all we were told
Trump won because of economic anxiety
the data now show that that was mostly
an empty explanation it wasn't a good
explanation however we do see evidence
that fear of losing social status as
well as racist and sexist beliefs were
positively correlated with support for
Donald Trump we also know that racism
and sexism are affiliated with lack of
intellectual capacity overall that's an
interesting data point we also have
another study unrelated to this one that
points similarly which says the
Democrats who chose to cross party lines
and vote for Trump were
disproportionately the ones who engaged
in lower levels of critical thinking
hello another data point that suggests
that tel-aviv University study that the
Tel Aviv University study is on to
something so I'm ready for the hate mail
David you guys are never gonna win by
insulting Trump voters I'm telling you
this because it's apparently the reality
based on the facts we have the reality
doesn't care about how you feel about
these results what does it tell us about
winning elections though that's really
the question because we know that
playing off of people's basic
fear-driven instincts works really well
we've known that for a while people are
not going to make informed analyses they
are overwhelmingly going to react
instinctively that's not new there's
something called the dunning-kruger
effect I interviewed David Dunning about
it some years ago the dunning-kruger
effect references people who lack the
cognitive ability to understand why they
misunderstand something so the question
is what do we do we know that things are
never as simple as simpletons make them
seem we know that real life is complex
it's mostly great gray area but is that
just a loser's path look at John Kerry
versus George Bush for example I've put
aside the potential irregularities in
Ohio during that election do we play the
game to win I don't know the answer I
really don't know the answer here and I
want to hear from you
out it because I don't know what we had
a call about this last week something
along the lines of should Democrats use
the tactics of the right to win in order
the debt to then actually do a
progressive agenda or are we quote
stooping to their level if we do that
and you know if we don't start winning
things are gonna get way worse so I
think at a certain point from a purely
pragmatic perspective you've got to say
we need to start winning at least using
the tactics that we know work one of the
most prominent Senate races this
November is incumbent extremist vile
disgusting depraved dilapidated I might
even say that makes sense
Texas Republican Ted Cruz against
Democratic challenger better or or we've
been talking about this one it's a tough
one taking out an incumbent Republican
in Texas is an uphill battle but if you
were able to remove such a toxic and
ridiculous Republican it would be a huge
victory it would be an absolutely
massive victory and what we learned
early this morning is that Ted Cruz is
declining to participate in a town hall
debate with Beto O'Rourke on CNN on
October 18th
they have debated already it didn't go
super well for Ted Cruz although it was
a lot of preaching to the choir like I
don't know that mines were necessarily
changed by that first debate I don't
think that baito did all that well
either he just sounded like a typical
politician could have attacked at
different points yeah it was 50/50 I
don't know if it moved the needle but
Ted Cruz is opting not to participate in
this town hall debate his campaign was
asked why he's not participating in this
one they haven't as of this morning
commented and so what that means is that
Beto or work is going to get a one hour
live townhall with voters on CNN and Ted
Cruz simply isn't going to be there now
that may actually help better or work
that might actually make a difference I
will say that Ted Cruz isn't just
avoiding all debate with Beto or Roarke
he already debated with him once there's
another debate scheduled for two days
prior to the Town Hall on October 16th
in San Antonio if Cruz showed up shows
up and as far as we know he is planning
to so there's kind of two major
storylines about why might Ted Cruz
decline an opportunity for now
a one-hour national appearance national
media appearance with his opponent the
right is saying Ted Cruz has no reason
to do this many debates he's killing it
in the race there's a new New York Times
poll which says Cruz's up nine against
Beto O'Rourke 53 to 44 with 3% undecided
which if you believe this thing's
basically over Ted Cruz is gonna win and
be reelected if you believe that you're
up 9 you might just say I don't need to
do two debates in a three days three
days span I just don't need to do that
there's also a level of possible
hypocrisy here because in 2016 Cruz
criticized Trump for canceling a
presidential debate to raise money for
veterans or something like that remember
when Ted Cruz said this Donald Trump has
decided not to participate in the Fox
News debate this upcoming Monday you
were ready to go John Kasich was ready
to go Kasich said he's not going to go
if Trump's not going and your response
to mr. Trump's decision well Megan it's
great to be with you and and for
whatever reason it seems that the Donald
Trump finds you a very very terrifying
person he skipped the debate dial what
cuz you were going to be moderating and
and I guess he doesn't like when anyone
challenges him you know he was saying
just a week ago that he was eager to get
one-on-one with me well this debate that
that the field is narrowed even more and
he could have had a direct debate with
me and yet Donald apparently is ducking
he's afraid of being challenged okay so
we've got Ted Cruz's position on debates
we've got the Republican idea that Cruz
doesn't need to debate because he's up
nine do I think that Cruz is actually up
nine probably not I think Democrats need
to get out in Texas I'm not pretending
this is an easy one Texas hasn't voted
for a Democratic presidential candidate
since 76 no Democrat has won statewide
office in Texas since 1994 but the left
wants to believe that the reason Ted
Cruz isn't debating is that the first
debate was such a disaster for him that
it did so much damage that he thinks
he's better off simply not showing up to
the town hall I don't really buy that I
don't really buy that that's why Ted
Cruz isn't showing up yeah I don't think
he's afraid of
knowing what he's talking about or bado
catching him and any traps that sort of
thing I think he's just afraid of some
sort of gaffe right that's what these
people try to avoid and if you're up by
nine points why do you have to subject
yourself to that possibility so let's
explore whether he's really up nine okay
there are internal polls which we've
learned about from sources inside Ted
Cruz's campaign which say that this is
not a nine-point spread that the
possibility of this race being within
the margin of error is a very real
possibility so I believe that the
reality is probably a combination of the
two on the one hand you do have public
polling showing Ted Cruz way ahead but
most of those public polls are based on
what's called a likely voter model and
what that does is it assesses the
likelihood that a voter is actually
going to vote and it only is a poll of
those that the model determines are
likely to vote young people are
underrepresented in likely voter models
because one question that you're asked
in determining your likelihood of voting
is have you voted before if you're 18 19
20 or 21 and you were not 18 at the time
of the last election you haven't voted
before therefore you are less likely to
vote according to these likely voter
models the young people are under
counted so I think the Cruz campaign
knows this I think they know that they
have internal polls that show that this
is much closer it doesn't look nearly as
good for Cruz as the nine-point lead
that the New York Times claims that he
has there has also been record high
turnout for Democratic registration in
Texas and Democratic primary turnout the
highest in 24 years so if you do a more
nuanced analysis of the polling data
from Texas you look at new voter
registrations you look at likely voter
models and understand how that probably
is hurting better or work in the polls
this actually could be much closer than
9 points do I think that Beto O'Rourke
is clearly in the lead
no at the best case scenario is that
it's within the margin of error right
now and I think it's safe to say that if
beta or Roarke does pull this off we're
gonna be seeing a huge blue wave of the
2018 midterms that would mean that
Democrats are taking the Senate and they
had a strong night yeah it wouldn't be
you wouldn't just have better or better
or work defeating Ted Cruz and no other
Democratic wave I think
the point you're making it's all that
these these races are correlated good
news is we don't have to wait that much
longer
early voting actually starts Monday
October 22nd you can be damn sure that I
will be reminding you that early voting
starts in just 12 days okay there is a
Republican state representative in
Minnesota named Duane quam and he seems
like a really angry guy he's running
against Jamie mahlberg who's female and
Jamie mahlberg is giving him a run for
his money
qualm has been the incumbent and he's
been in for four terms he's the
Republican Jamie mahlberg is the
Democrat they had a debate where they
had to share a microphone which sounds
crazy it's not ideal but in local races
these sorts of things can happen at
debates where even though you've got two
candidates there's just one microphone
available and you've got to pass it back
and forth Jamie qualms got a I'm sorry
not not Jamie qualms Duane qualms I
combined their names
Duane qualm got a turn answering a
question then it was Jamie mal Burke's
turn to respond and as she finishes
speaking qualm rips the microphone from
her hand and she sort of jumps her
startles and it's all on video let's
take a look and you can hear the crowd
sort of gasp taken aback when he grabs
the mic out of her hand that formula
increases over time with inflation thank
you the problem we've got in education
is we are funding failure so he gets
this very angry rebuttal which also was
just terrible policy I mean his
education policy is also terrible but
maybe we'll get to that and then when
he's done with this rebuttal he goes to
hand the mic back to Jamie mahlberg and
she doesn't immediately take it she just
sort of seems to want nothing to do with
this guy and he tosses the mic at her
and if you're listening to what we're
about to play and not watching it like
if you're listening on the radio or on
the audio podcast you're gonna hear a
crashing sound and that's him throwing a
live microphone on to the table in front
of Jamie mahlberg take a look and the
formula builds in funding failure
okay thank you for the rebuttal and so
in the next question what a disgusting
human being and I was watching this I
don't know how many people have seen the
film office space the cult classic
office space
this guy's physical appearance reminds
and his demeanor reminds me of a cross
between Milton from office space and Tom
from office space we have a side by side
by side but I that I made yesterday and
you'll see Dwayne Wade qualms on the
left Milton from office space in the
middle and Tom from office space on the
right
unfortunate it's an unfortunate thing
yeah this is the new civility anyway he
later apologized and said he he ripped
the mic out of her hand and and threw it
back at her because he was nervous and
that's kind of funny because if Dwayne
qualm was running against another big
male like him would nervousness also
lead to him snatching the mic from his
opponent and then throwing it back at
them or is that something that
nervousness causes only when you're
sitting next to a woman like Jaimie
mahlberg I'm just asking God oh yes I
get nervous I started attacking people
borderline and get triggered in this way
maybe this is smart in some way like
maybe in the era of Trump this is what
Republican voters in Minnesota want to
see I mean I guess it's possible
although I don't know that much about
this this particular district and then
moat to kind of bring it back full
circle his rebuttal also was a rebuttal
of terrible actual ideas about education
that he espouses like his ideas as bad
as snatching the microphone from his
opponent and then throwing it back at
her his ideas about education are maybe
even more atrocious and disgusting yeah
he sounded so excited so ready to talk
about education policy and then when you
listen to his answer it's the void of
any meaning it's horrible
would you be shocked pat if I told you
that no one respects women more than
this guy like would that would that be
believable or would you question I think
I've heard that somewhere before
he respects women second most behind
someone else I'm thinking of he has
binders full of women who want nothing
nothing to do with him what so
ever anyway if you're a voter in this
district you can vote this guy out in
November I encourage you to do that
and I also encourage you to follow the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show follow me on instagram at
david pakman part two of my interview
with Nathan J Robinson is coming up next
importantly about the intellectual dark
web a subject which Nathan J Robinson is
written about a lot do we call him
Nathan J Robinson because there are
other Nathan Robinson's that are
prominent oh yeah former basketball
player not the NBA point guard they were
about to have on for the interview I
don't think there's another Nathan
Robinson as well I like that Nathan J
Robinson just to make it super clear
that's like remember uh that lawyer
howard case stern who would go because
he didn't want to be confused with
Howard Stern the radio host so he would
go by Howard case there and even though
like he's Howard Stern just like the
other Howard's there it almost makes you
want to have a middle initial right just
in case there's any confusion between
you and another document the other David
Pakman has a middle name so I'm just
David Pakman the other David Pakman is
David B Pakman so you can't like if
somebody says David B Pakman its the
venture capitalist that actually works
out for you pretty well oh I wasn't get
to keep your full name and the Wikipedia
page for David Pakman is mine and you
have to go to David B Pakman to find his
Wikipedia page which is great right I
mean that works out great for me this
almost makes me want to snatch the
microwave from you please do okay please
vote that's I feel like that's my Jeb
Bush please clap please vote in November
because we've got to get this guy out
quick break Nathan J Robinson and then a
lot of other great stuff going on today
hey this next story is just unbelievable
I've talked to you about the tension
between Donald Trump and his chief of
staff John Kelly before I don't agree
with Kelly's politics but you can't
really deny that he is sort of at least
compared to Trump more of a no-nonsense
type of guy and we saw very shortly
after John Kelly became chief of staff
replacing who was it rinse Priebus right
he was that the you saw the sort of
pushing out from the inner circle of the
more extreme flow
like Steven Bannon and the wacky Anthony
scaramouche's from Trump's inner circle
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
they lost influence but at least
publicly Kelly Cohen Kelly coming in
coincided with them being pushed out of
being so publicly and visibly close to
Donald Trump there's a really
interesting new report from New York
Times
magda New York Magazine rather written
by Olivia newton-john 'old Trump has
actually tried to fire chief of staff
John Kelly several times but that John
Kelly ignores it and that Trump is sort
of like unsure how the fire john kelly
he usually calls john kelly to fire
other people and he i just imagined
trump sitting at the white house looking
at his phone going who can I call to
fire Kelly because I can't I can't have
Melania do it doesn't seem Kushner's got
the I don't know how to fire the guy
that's what it seems is going on here
this is just the best a White House
official spoke to Olivia Newton ooh York
Magazine piece on the condition of
anonymity and said to her and is quoted
in the article is saying when the
president says I need you to leave Kelly
just ignores him I think the president
just doesn't know who to call to fire
him normally if the president wanted to
fire somebody he would call Kelly to do
it but there's nobody else to call this
is extraordinary I actually don't know
whether to say it's hilarious or the
stuff of nightmares
because it indicates a level of
dysfunction and incompetence that we
definitely suspected but maybe didn't
realize was actually did this this bad
and this egregious but it all fits with
what else has been reported right it's
been reported previously that John Kelly
thinks Trump is an idiot has referred to
him as an idiot in private has referred
to him as unhinged in private it's been
record reported by Politico that while
John Kelly is still chief of staff in
name like he's formerly still the chief
of staff but is no longer really chief
of staff because Trump has stopped
taking advice from him and it's been
reported multiple times that Kelly might
be on his way out so the story's
coherent with the broader narrative that
we're aware of
but Trump
being unsure of how to get rid of this
guy and Kelly ignoring Trump's attempts
to fire him is another level of
incompetence altogether I would have
liked to see Trump take the Jeff
Sessions approach on this which is not
to directly try to fire him but just to
go on a bunch of like cable news shows
and make it known that he wants this guy
out yeah call him beleaguered and the
rest of it now it didn't work with
sessions but it actually has worked with
others and this is this is the funny so
part of this I can't tell if it's scary
or funny the one definitely funny part
is why can't Trump just sit Kelly down
privately and just say listen we're
letting you go
I'm serious I need you out today I've
notified Secret Service and you're gonna
be out today isn't Trump supposedly the
Alpha who's known for telling people
that their fires like on his old reality
show that's what he would do he would
tell people you're you're just out
you're fired and they would go and it's
also funny that for that same reason on
some level Trump is a coward
right Trump is a coward a ton of the
people fired by Trump as you mentioned
Pat it didn't work with sessions but
they learned about it through the media
Rex Tillerson I believe found out via
Twitter that he was going to be let go
Trump didn't call him and say we're
letting you go James Comey as FBI a
former FBI agent Josh Campbell has told
the story James Comey found out when he
was speaking to I don't know if it was
FBI or see he was been giving a speech
somewhere and there was like a TV tuned
to Fox News in the back of the room and
that's how James Comey found out that he
had been fired so this actually is a
pattern Trump usually will leak to the
media or tweet or something like that as
opposed to just sitting down and saying
we're letting you go
maybe it's because Trump has so much
admiration for these military types oh
yeah John Kelly definitely fits that
description huger's Trump always talks
about how great Mad Dog Madison for
example and even after firing Michael
Flynn he expressed some regret about
that like yeah we can we can invite him
back into the administration under a
different title I would like to see him
just take responsibility put on the big
boy pants and do it like an adult who
manages people and is in charge of
hiring and firing just do it
as opposed to this pathetic nonsense
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman follow me and follow the show on
Twitter at David Pakman show I've got a
great one for you including part two of
my interview with Nathan J Robinson
about the intellectual dark web it's
coming up a little bit later on in the
continued authoritarian nepeta stays
that a word crony istic slide Donald
Trump in the wake of the announcement of
UN Ambassador Nikki Haley's resignation
for unknown in questionable reasons
possibly involving a federal ethics
probe that's been requested Donald Trump
has said that there could be no one more
competent in the world to replace UN
Ambassador nikki Haley than his own
daughter Ivanka Trump now you probably
are hearing me say this and you're
thinking David you must have
misunderstood it must be an onion
article or a really good impression on
SNL it can't really be that Trump said
something like this oh no it's on video
that's exactly what Donald Trump said
take a look at this I've heard a lot of
them I've heard Ivanka I've heard how
good would Ivanka be the people that
know there's nothing to do with nepotism
but I want to tell you the people that
know know that Ivanka would be dynamite
but you know I'd then be accused of
nepotism if you can believe it right you
believe
[Music]
I think Ivanka would be incredible that
doesn't mean you know it I figure
because you'd be accused of nepotism
even though I'm not sure there's anybody
more confident in the world but that's
okay but but we are looking at numerous
people I like that you know I even cut
my own daughter would be the best person
to actually be ambassador to the UN but
if you can believe this crazy thing I'd
be accused of nepotism yeah I can
believe it that's the definition of
nepotism well I'm gonna defend the
president here for a second because in
Trump circles yeah perhaps Ivanka is the
most competent one like people like
Scarah Moochie working for him and
Kellyanne Conway and Ryan Spicer Ivanka
is better than all of them but he said
not the most qualified in DC or in my
administration he said the most
competent in the world I love how he
says nepotism but forgetting about
nepotism for a second Ivanka would be
the best but people would say nepotism
so that's the problem the problem is not
that he immediately starts thinking
about could I put a member of my family
in this position maybe he goes too it
would be something that the left would
slam me for unfairly of course would
Ivanka Trump be considered as ambassador
to the UN as a possibility by any other
president or even by any other person
outside of trumps family were Trump not
president the answer's no she would only
even enter someone's mind as a possible
ambassador to the UN on the basis of
being Trump's kid which means of course
that it is nepotism and I'm going to
tell you right now I know people in the
audience may not like this if Donald
Trump wants Ivanka as ambassador to the
UN Trump probably gets Ivanka as
ambassador to the UN right the
debasement of our politics and of all
that is good and proper means Trump
probably wouldn't be stopped I mean who
would do it are Republicans in the House
or Senate gonna punish Trump for making
Ivanka ambassador to the UN no if Trump
wants her in there look I'm not saying
he actually wants her in there but if he
did Fox and Friends would start talking
about why not Ivanka she knows everybody
she's well-liked she's respect
I mean great great person great body
Trump has told us about her great body
many times it was weird when he said it
but he did I don't think they stop it if
Trump really wants I mean there are
anti-nepotism laws on the books
yeah but they could skirt around them
that's how they got Ivanka into the
White House as an advisor on pages you
just don't pay her yeah and I think
that's a sacrifice she would be willing
to make this would be different this
seems as though it would go against five
US codes subsection 31 10 about the
employment of relatives but who cares
because it hasn't mattered so far and
the law says that during a national
security crisis the president all of a
sudden can appoint a relative they'll
say there are Mexicans pouring in it is
a national security crisis therefore
Ivanka as ambassador to the UN or the
Russia probe is a national security
crisis we've got to put Ivanka Trump in
as ambassador to the UN and Ivanka Trump
she knows China
she knows Japan absolutely she knows
India she's the perfect fit I would say
don't stop here I would say go further
Donald Trump jr. for Secretary of State
get the North Korea thing straightened
out once and for all Pompey owes failing
put in Don Junior Baron Trump can be a
head of cyber security of course he and
Tiffani Trump may be like deputy press
secretary but not really doesn't like
their yeah Trump really doesn't like
Tiffany does he know this is the third
ring of the circus okay it's all coming
full circle we've got the debasement of
our politics and culture too grotesque
clothes we've got as I mentioned twice
now in the last 48 hours the
radicalization of institutions of
government including the Supreme Court
including the Environmental Protection
Agency our voting systems the courts
media and then the fully authoritarian I
would call it a day Newmont
of officially pushing his family into
positions of power official positions
not just I have an office near daddies
and I hang out but nobody pays me we're
in real trouble
you had better vote next month seriously
let me know what your thoughts are I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show and we'll
be back after this the voter purges are
happening and we've only got three four
weeks to fix it I guess we are is today
the three
or either three or four weeks away cuz
it's Tuesday number six yes all right
four weeks for regress away 31 days in
October that makes sense and there's
only four weeks to fix it to the day if
you've been kicked off of the voter
rolls and they're I don't even know
where we could approach this story from
like ten different angles but I'll tell
you one sort of data point which is that
there's a growing federal lawsuit
against the Office of Brian Kemp he's
the secretary of state of Georgia and
the lawsuit against Kemp says that for
the last two years he's been using a
racially based method to remove about
700,000 voters legitimate voters people
who should be on the voter rolls from
the registered voter list and not only
has their methodology for removing
voters been racially tinged they also
aren't even notifying voters of their
removal so that voters would know and
the deadline to re register is lo and
behold
today so from what we know so far it's
disproportionately Democrats and
non-white voters who have been removed
what is Kemp the Georgia Secretary of
State saying well he's weaselly you
really have to look at the letter of
what he's saying to understand what's
going on he put out a statement which
says quote this threatens lawsuit has no
merit to be crystal clear Georgia has
never used data from the cross-check
program to conduct Lintz list
maintenance in any capacity zero voters
have been removed from the rolls based
on cross-check data in this state Greg
Palast is completely blind to this
indisputable fact in his pursuit of a
sensationalist headline real journalists
have already reported that Georgia does
not use this data for realist
maintenance frankly mr. Palace should be
embarrassed and any credibility that he
had left is now completely destroyed a
lot of focus on Greg Palast not so much
focus on the 700,000 people who are no
longer on the voter rolls he's focusing
on cross-check but cross-check is not
the only way people are now being
removed his statement can be true in
other words it can be true that they're
not doing list maintenance with
cross-check data but they're still
applying other methods to purge voters
period and this
even the first time Kemp has been
accused of this the same guy was sued in
2016 for the same thing right before the
presidential election we're dealing with
horrible people here in 2017 just after
the lawsuit was filed over what happened
in 2016 the computer server which was
crucial to figuring out what happened in
Georgia
bad luck Pat it was wiped clean
what a terrible coincidence the exact
server that we needed to see whether
illegal voter purges has happened just
wiped clean
oops must have bleached it what did they
wipe it with a cloth they wiped it with
cloth yeah they wiped it with cloth and
did a very extensive meth use the
extensive methods that Trump thinks
exist the state of Georgia has a website
so that you can check if you're
registered we're linking to it in the
YouTube video description you can also
just google Georgia my voter page it
should be the first thing the first
result that comes up but the problem
isn't just in Georgia there are similar
lawsuits all over the country Kansas is
a classic of course led by Trump
henchman and secretary of state Kris
Kobach whose mission to uncover voter
fraud by Hillary Clinton to the tune of
three to five million votes in 2016 fell
totally flat he's still able to wreak
havoc in Kansas though yes soon-to-be
Governor probably attentionally Bach
soon-to-be governor which is a little
bit disgusting yeah this is part of the
Cavanaugh solution right it's really
important to understand the connection
between this and kiauna Republicans are
pushing anti-democracy all over the
country in multiple institutions voting
is one Republicans with Cavanaugh as a
right word move from Anthony Kennedy on
the Supreme Court gonna have this wide
open door to put more laws in place at
the state and national and local level
to prevent people from voting
specifically people they don't want
voting and they know how to do it here's
one idea maybe people receiving certain
types of federal or state aid shouldn't
be allowed to vote until they get off of
that aid that's been floated already
would that pass under the current
Supreme Court I don't know but these are
the ideas they're thinking about this
exist in dozens of it in iterations but
that's like a kernel of an idea and
you're gonna need the Supreme Court for
that stuff and now they have an even
more radical Supreme Court with Brett
Kavanaugh and to those who say well
George is a red state so what does it
really matter Democrats are gonna win
there anyway you're wrong because there
are 14 House districts up for grabs
you know many of those are in Atlanta
and the suburbs Savannah the same thing
and Democrats are you could definitely
make a play in some of those races not
only that I think Georgia has the first
sort of prominent major party black
gubernatorial candidate I believe I
think there's a democratic woman who's
african-american who's running as well
and that has escalated the the attempt
to reduce early voting hours in
democratic and black areas and they
don't have any Senate elections this
time around but they will in two years
and I actually remember in 2016 after
the Access Hollywood tapes came out yeah
they were saying that Georgia is in play
for Hillary Clinton so I got that state
going forward and this stuff will
certainly affect that make sure that if
you believe you are registered that you
actually are in every state there's a
website or I think every state I don't
know exactly what's going on in some of
those states but I know most states do
you have websites where you can confirm
your voter registration